l'année prochaine si on veut qu'elle
revienne il faudra crier aline pour
remettre le césar de la meilleure
actrice valérie lemercier
[Musique]
à
j'ai pas l'habitude de raconter ma vie
mais là exceptionnellement ce soir
j'avoue avec le désoeuvrement jeu quand
même l'impression que je déconne ap un
tube en ce moment oui il ya une semaine
je me suis même inscrits sur le site
empreinte mon toutou 90 lui c'est vrai
ça consiste à promener les chiens des
gens et donc à faire faire caca des
chiens pour ne connaît pas alors que
j'ai peur des chiens et du caca et même
de mon propre kaka enfin propres dépens
des des jours voilà alors merci de
m'avoir écouté et je peux vous dire que
je suis contente de sortir de chez moi
pour autre chose
une petite sortie ça fait toujours
plaisir